[Applaudissements]
le principe est simple on arrête des
gens dans la rue on leur pose une
question absolument sans intérêt
juste le temps pour nous d'aller se
changer juste à côté dans un camion et
revenir à billets comme comme eux on
reste quand même aux environs de grève
qu il regarde c'est magnifique
[Musique]
watson paris le côté bon d du métro
voilà ne repousse un petit peu et votre
n en pense quoi
mon frère fuck off quoi c'est ballot ces
champs a [ __ ] on les prend le moins
possible c'est vous bas je trouve que
les transports sens très bien en
revanche un bain co investissent plus
c'est qu'on continue à a forcé un peu ce
rôle investissement et votre elle en
pense quoi
je les trouve bien le métro couvre
beaucoup le beaucoup de journées
beaucoup de lignes de votre elle en
pense quoi
je prends souvent les transports la vie
car il s'est pas mal de
de transition et votre à ils en pensent
quoi tes temps du temps du temps du trô
ne dirige pas tendu c'était tendu mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même des
retards réguliers qui sont assez assez
perturbant dans l'organisation
quotidienne ou en blanc et votre à elle
en pense quoi
c'est trop bête franchement c'est trop
bête ces transports on aime bien et tout
emoji hashtag rer quoi
[Musique]
lojeski
[Applaudissements]